wir werden immer dicker in fast allen
Ländern geht der BMI nach oben und das
ist tödlich oder mindestens schlecht und
ungesund würden vermutlich die meisten
sagen gleichzeitig gibt es das Buddy
positivity movement das sagt wir sollten
mehr Körperformen akzeptieren wie sie
sind und Gesundheit gibt es bei jedem
Gewicht okay aber wer hat denn jetzt
recht ist Übergewicht wirklich ungesund
oder nicht wir haben lange recherchiert
mit mehreren Experten gesprochen
wissenschaftliche Studien gelesen und
dabei gelernt dass wir nicht einmal halb
so viel über diese super spannende Thema
wussten wie wir vorher dachten steigt
mit uns ein in diese sehr komplexe aber
wichtige Thematik
[Musik]
Trigger warning in diesem Video geht es
um Übergewicht es geht um Ernährung und
um psychische Krankheiten wenn ihr das
also nicht sehen wollt dann klickt jetzt
besser weg okay lass uns als allererstes
mal mit einem Mythos aufräumen wenn ein
Arzt herausfinden will ob ich
übergewichtig bin dann wird er
wahrscheinlich meinen Body-Mass-Index
kurz BMI berechnen dafür teilt man
einfach das Körpergewicht durch die
Körpergröße im Quadrat und Übergewicht
ist wenn man einen BMI von über 25 hat
ab 30 redet man von krankhaftem
Übergewicht also Adipositas so zumindest
definiert dass das Robert-Koch-Institut
oder auch die WHO das habe ich auch
damals in der Schule gelernt was ich
aber nicht gelernt habe ist dass der BMI
alleine für mich relativ unbrauchbar ist
denn der BMI ist zu einfach beim
Berechnen zählen ja nur zwei Dinge Größe
und Gewicht ab 5 Kilo mehr Muskeln oder
5 kg mehr Fett macht hier keinen
Unterschied Arnold Schwarzenegger wäre
also mit seinem wettbewerbsgewicht von
107 Kilogramm bei einem BMI von über 30
und damit krankhaft fettleibig das zeigt
dass der BMI alleine auf individueller
Ebene nicht reicht um uns etwas über
unsere Gesundheit zu sagen aber Spoiler
wir werden trotzdem in diesem Video über
den BMI reden und damit sind wir wie
gesagt nicht alleine aber warum rechnen
RKI und who mit dem Body-Mass-Index wenn
er doch so inakurate ist naja der BMI
ist so ziemlich das Beste was wir haben
wenn es darum geht sich die Gesellschaft
und nicht einzelne Menschen anzuschauen
er lässt sich nämlich schnell berechnen
detaillierte Tests die sich Knochen
Fettgewebe oder ähnliches anschauen sind
komplizierter zu erheben als der BMI
dazu kommt wir berechnen ihn schon eine
gefühlte Ewigkeit das heißt wir haben
sehr viele Daten es ist einfach besser
mit alten vielleicht etwas unpräzisen
aber dafür umfangreichen Daten zu
arbeiten deswegen können wir mit dem BMI
gesellschaftlich Entwicklungen sehen und
die gehen ganz klar in eine Richtung
2,6 Milliarden Menschen waren 2020
übergewichtig 988 Millionen davon
fettleibig also krankhaft übergewichtig
und wenn es so weitergeht dann ist 2035
jeder zweite Mensch auf dem Planeten
übergewichtig warum das so ist ist
kompliziert klar im Grunde genommen kann
Gewichtszunahme nur passieren wenn
unterm Strich mehr Energie zu sich
genommen wird als vom Körper verbrannt
wird aber warum die global mehr Kalorien
essen als noch vor 30 oder 40 Jahren ist
eigentlich ein eigenes Video-Thema fest
steht aber wir werden dicker aber werden
wir dadurch auch ungesünder bevor wir
Äpfel mit Birnen vergleichen müssen wir
erst einmal klären was gesund überhaupt
bedeutet ganz allgemein gesagt verbinden
wir mit Gesundheit die Abwesenheit von
Krankheit das greift aber wahrscheinlich
für dieses Video zu kurz auch die whode
definiert Gesundheit mittlerweile etwas
breiter als physisches soziales und
psychisches Wohlergehen und genau so
wollen wir das hier auch machen
machen wir es kurz statistisch gesehen
steigen mit einem BMI über 30 die
gesundheitlichen Risiken deswegen
definiert die WHO oder auch das RKI
alles ab 30 als Krankheit aber ganz so
einfach ist es dann doch nicht denn man
kann sowohl übergewichtig als auch kern
gesund sein
individuell gesehen müsste man es also
eigentlich so formulieren sehr dick zu
sein ist wahrscheinlich
langfristig schlecht für die Gesundheit
2020 kam eine Studie heraus bei der fast
3 Millionen Erwachsene in England für 11
Jahre begleitet wurden Teilnehmerinnen
und Teilnehmer mit einem BMI zwischen 30
und 35 also Adipositas 1 hatten eine 5
Mal höhere Chance an Diabetes zu
erkranken bei einem BMI von 40 oder 45
war das Risiko 12 Mal so hoch dazu kommt
dass Adipositas mit verschiedenen
Herzkrankheiten Schlaganfällen oder z.B
Krebs korreliert so weit so erwartet war
gleichzeitig lassen sich bei stark
übergewichtigen Menschen teil Weise
bessere Blutzucker oder Cholesterinwerte
feststellen mit fortschreitendem Alter
würden mit einem leicht erhöhten BMI
auch eine bessere Lebenserwartung
verbunden das Übergewicht ist also quasi
eine Reserve für kräftezehrende
Krankheiten und es gibt einfach Menschen
die zu viel wiegen aber kerngesund sind
wie kann Übergewicht scheinbar
gleichzeitig ungesund für die einen und
unbedenklich für die anderen sein
wie Übergewicht meine Gesundheit
gefährdet kommt wahrscheinlich darauf an
auf welche Art ich übergewichtig bin
denn wo und wie der Körperfett speichert
macht einen großen Unterschied
überschüssiges viszerales Fett also Fett
in der Bauchhöhle um die inneren Organe
und das Verdauungssystem herum wird mit
mehr Entzündungserscheinungen in
Verbindung gebracht denn wissen alles
Fett nimmt mehr Einfluss auf unsere
Hormone und den Stoffwechsel und Fett
was sich in Organen wie zum Beispiel der
Leber ansetzt ist auch gefährlicher als
Fett was ich einfach unter der Haut
ansetzt was teilweise sogar gut für uns
ist
dick heißt also nicht zwangsläufig
ungesund es kommt darauf an wo der
Körper das Fett speichert und das ist
bei jedem anders das ist aber auch noch
nicht alles denn die Wissenschaft hat
Hinweise dass es Menschen gibt die
einfach von Natur aus mit den negativen
Folgen von Übergewicht besser umgehen
können da gibt es zum Beispiel dieses
paper hier das ziemlich hohe Wellen
geschlagen hat die Forschenden haben 62
gehen Orte gefunden die sowohl mit
höherem Körperfett in Verbindung stehen
als auch mit einem niedrigen Risiko an
Stoffwechsel und Herzerkrankungen zu
leiten kurz darauf kam auch diese Studie
hier raus hier wurden 45 übergewichtige
Menschen mit Stoffwechselerkrankungen 45
gesunde übergewichtige sowie 25
normalgewichtige Menschen miteinander
verglichen und bei den ungesunden
übergewichtigen Teilnehmern hat man in
den Fettzellen mehr Fasergewebe gefunden
was auch dafür spricht dass es
individuelle körperliche Unterschiede
gibt wie gesund Übergewicht sein kann
Menschen die resistent gegen die
ungesunden Folgen von Übergewicht sein
sollen nennt man mho
metabolically healthy overweight wo
genau die Grenzen zwischen Majo und
ungesundem Übergewicht verlaufen ist
aber ziemlich umstritten Zahlen die wir
gefunden haben sprechen davon dass 6 bis
60% aller übergewichtigen mho sein
könnten das ist aber so eine riesige
Spanne dass das quasi alleine
entscheiden würde ob Übergewicht eher
ungesund ist oder nicht andere Zahlen
identifizieren in einer riesigen Studie
40% von 12000 Amerikanern und 20% von
374 000 Engländern als Mao definiert
wurde mho hier am Blutdruck Hüftumfang
der Krankheitsgeschichte der letzten 14
Jahre sowie über die Blutzuckerwerte
leider gibt es hier noch keine finale
Antwort wann Übergewicht gesund sein
könnte aber eben Hinweise generell lässt
sich sagen dass Übergewicht körperlich
gesünder ist wenn man jünger weiblich
und nicht adipös ist besonders
entscheidend ist ein BMI unter 30 und
das alter Junge Körper können
beispielsweise Adipositas noch viel
besser wegstecken im Alter wird es dann
aber zu einem Problem und das bietet
vielleicht eine neue Definition von
physisch gesundem Übergewicht es ist
kein definitives Urteil sondern ein
Zustand der sich im Alter in ungesundes
Übergewicht entwickeln könnte das
unterstützt auch diese Studie hier die
These alles was Menschen zu
metabolically healthy overweight macht
ist keine Immunität sondern eine
Verlangsamung der potentiell schädlichen
Folgen von Übergewicht von Folgen für
Gelenke und Knochen sind gesunde
adipositaspatienten übrigens auch nicht
befreit ergo trotz all der Unklarheiten
ist es wahrscheinlich besser abzunehmen
wenn man an die böse ist das Risiko das
daraus mal ein gesundheitliches Problem
werden könnte ist nach dem aktuellen
Wissensstand einfach zu hoch das
Übergewicht an sich ist aber nicht das
einzige Gesundheitsrisiko für dicke
Menschen wir sehen gerade mehr und mehr
Studien die herausgefunden haben dass
übergewichtige Menschen öfter an
leichtvermeidbaren gesundheitlichen
Problemen leiden und das nicht wegen des
Übergewichts an sich viele haben Sorgen
zum Arzt zu gehen und dort verurteilt zu
werden und das stimmt auch denn wir
sehen dass übergewichtige tatsächlich
oft eine schlechtere Behandlung bekommen
weil auch unter Fachpersonal starke
negative Meinungen und Vorurteile
herrschen die Studien dazu findet ihr
übrigens unten in der Videobeschreibung
und damit kommen wir auch schon zu einem
Teil der hier in der Diskussion
besonders wichtig ist denn bei der
ganzen Diskussion über die Gesundheit
von übergewichtigen bleibt ein wichtiger
Punkt oft links liegen wie die
Gesellschaft mit übergewichtigen
Menschen umgeht und das ist eindeutig
ungesund denn negative soziale
Erfahrungen von denen viele
übergewichtige Menschen ein Lied singen
können sorgen für physiologische
stressantworten die unserem Körper und
unsere Psyche schaden
ständiges gewichtsstigma führt zu einem
erhöhten Ausstoß von Cortisol was
wiederum zu Stoffwechselproblemen sowie
Gewichtszunahme führen kann das ist ein
Teufelskreis dazu kann dann kommen das
betroffene diesen Stress mit Alkohol und
Drogen behandeln und oder sich
zurückziehen und soziale Kontakte
vermeiden auch das ist alles andere als
geil für die Gesundheit im Ernstfall
entsteht durch das Übergewicht Stigma
chronischer sozialer Stress der im
Zusammenhang mit einer 60% erhöhten
Mortalität steht 60 %. und jetzt kommt
der Hammer selbst wenn der BMI unter 25
also im Bereich des Normalen Gewichts
zwar hat man diese erhöhte Mortalität
feststellen können das heißt es reicht
vielleicht sich selber als übergewichtig
wahrzunehmen oder wahrgenommen zu werden
um die psychischen Folgen zu spüren und
es könnte sogar sein dass die
Konsequenzen aus Mobbing und
Stigmatisierung schlimmer für unseren
Körper sind als das eigentliche
Übergewicht das wollen jetzt schon
mehrere paper herausgefunden haben
allerdings waren Wissenschaftler mit
denen wir gesprochen haben hier etwas
vorsichtiger es ist natürlich auch
generell schwierig zu messen was
individuell schlimmer empfunden wird was
wir aber definitiv wissen ist das dicke
Leute
öfter an Depressionen leiden dazu wird
gerade wahnsinnig viel geforscht zum
Beispiel in dieser Studie hier die
Ergebnisse ein Großteil der Depressionen
kommt durch psychosoziale Effekte also
das worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben
Mobbing Verurteilung Benachteiligung
aber rechnet man die psychosozialen
Gründe raus sind übergewichtige Leute
immer noch auffällig depressiver ein
Grund dafür könnte die systemwhite
inflammation sein das ganze ist super
kompliziert daher hier nur die einfache
Kurzfassung beim Stoffwechsel entstehen
quasi Reste die unser Körper regelmäßig
loswerden muss und das tut er nur wenn
wir ab und zu mal einen Tag mehr Energie
verlieren als wir zu uns nehmen z.B
durch Sport oder weniger essen wenn wir
das alles nicht loswerden dann baut sich
quasi einen Backlog von
stoffwechselresten in uns auf das führt
zu Entzündungsreaktionen und diese
beeinflussen nicht nur unserem Körper
sondern machen uns auch depressiv aber
das alles muss nicht mal nur am
Übergewicht liegen ähnliche
Entzündungserscheinungen werden auch bei
dünnen Menschen festgestellt die sich
einfach nicht besonders gut ernähren zum
Beispiel spielen Transfette hier eine
Rolle auch das zeigt wieder Übergewicht
und die Krankheiten die daraus entstehen
können sind vielschichtig und
multifaktoriell
wie fasst man das jetzt alles zusammen
ist Übergewicht wirklich ungesund also
erstmal nur am BMI die individuelle
Gesundheit festzustellen ist unmöglich
denn viszerales Fett also Bauchfett ist
gefährlicher als ein hoher BMI sehr
spannend sind hier ein paar Studien die
zeigen dass Menschen problemlos einen
normalen BMI haben können und
gleichzeitig gesundheitlich quasi adipös
sind der BMI bildet das einfach nur
nicht ab am wichtigsten ist es glaube
ich noch mal klar zu sagen die
Krankheiten die mit Übergewicht
korrelieren entstehen nicht einfach
automatisch durch mehr Fett vielmehr
sind sie eine komplizierte Verkettung
von Genetik und individuellen
körperlichen unterschieden und
Eigenheiten in der breiten Bevölkerung
wissen wir dass es rein statistisch
vermehrt zu diesen Krankheiten kommt auf
individueller Ebene sind es aber eben
viele kleine und größere weichen die
Übergewicht krankhaft machen oder eben
auch nicht und hier spielt das Ausmaßes
über Gewicht wahrscheinlich eine
entscheidende Rolle die Ärzte mit denen
wir dieses Video hier gesprochen haben
waren sich einig dass Adipositas also
ein BMI von über 30 zu Recht als
Krankheit eingestuft wird gesünder wird
es definitiv bei einem BMI unter 30
vielleicht sogar trotz leichtem
Übergewicht die Gefahr dass aber auch
hier eine Krankheit entstehen kann
bleibt ähnlich kompliziert ist es wie
übergewicht entsteht Hormone soziale
psychosoziale und genetische Gründe
bestimmen wann wir hungrig und wann satt
sind übergewicht ist nicht einfach
Charakterschwäche sondern ein
komplizierter Zustand der ernsthaft
ungesund sein kann aber nicht die Schuld
der Person selbst ist und wer über die
Gesundheit von übergewichtigen reden
möchte der muss die psychische Belastung
von dicken Menschen zum Thema machen es
ist einfach krass welchen
gesundheitlichen Risiken dicke Menschen
ausgesetzt sind die absolut nichts mit
ihrem Übergewicht selbst zu tun haben
und vieles davon kann auch
internalisiert werden so war das bei mir
ich habe mich die längste Zeit meines
Lebens als zu dick betrachtet uns
darunter lutscht man Selbstwertgefühl
und noch viele andere Dinge bis ich dann
im Januar 2021 beschlossen habe
abzunehmen gemacht habe ich das mit
Kalorienzählen weil das eine super
akkurate und sehr wissenschaftliche
Methode ist das passt zu mir und das
muss natürlich nicht zu jedem passen die
App die mir erlaubt hat über 16
Kilogramm abzunehmen heißt yazio und da
ich sie so toll fand haben wir uns bei
yazio gemeldet und nach einer
Zusammenarbeit gefragt die jetzt auch
stattfindet denn ja sie unterstützt
dieses Video hier netterweise die App
funktioniert sehr einfach hat aber viele
nützliche Funktionen erstmal geht die an
was ihr gerade liegt und was ihr gerne
wiegen würdet daraus berechnet yazio
dann wie viel Kalorien ihr jeden Tag zu
euch nehmen solltet dank der großen
Datenbank könnt ihr dann einfach alles
was sie den Tag über so es per Barcode
einscannen oder eintragen ich habe mir
dann auch relativ schnell ja so pro
geholt weil das noch mal mehr Features
hat zum Beispiel intervallfasten was mir
persönlich sehr viel geholfen hat oder
das Aufzeichnen von anderen Körper
werden die Körperfett und Muskelmasse
was ich aber damals nicht hatte ist ein
rabatt-link von Dr Watson über 40% für
ein Jahr über diesen Link hier yazio
Punkt mi / Watson zahlt ihr für yazio
Pro nur 2,50 € im Monat abnehmen hat
mein Leben verändert zum Besseren und ja
SEO hat mir dabei geholfen man könnte
also argumentieren dass yazio mein Leben
verändert hat wenn ihr euch die App auch
runterladen wollt dann klickt auf dem
ersten Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung dann bekommt ihr auch
meinen Rabatt und findet dort auch meine
fünf wichtigsten Tipps zum Abnehmen die
Forschung lernt gerade sehr sehr viel
Übergewicht ständig kommen neue Studien
raus die sich mehr mit dem Individuum
und weniger mit der Gesellschaft
beschäftigen und das ist wahnsinnig
spannend wir sollten also offen bleiben
und versuchen Übergewicht neu zu
verstehen noch bis vor kurzem war ein
operativer Eingriff quasi das einzige
was wirklich immer geholfen hat Döner zu
werden mittlerweile sind aber die ersten
funktionierenden Medikamente da die beim
Abnehmen helfen ja es gibt jetzt
tatsächlich echte abnehmen Pillen nicht
nur irgendwelche TV werbescams wenn wir
darüber ein Video machen sollen dann
schreibt uns das gerne in die Kommentare
ansonsten könnt ihr hier gerne schauen
wie ich über ich glaube 16 Kilo
abgenommen habe und ansonsten wie immer
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig
Arnold Schwarzenegger wäre also mit
seinem Wettbewerbs gesehen Gesicht